a judge has ordered armed gunmen away
from ballot drop boxes but not all the
way away
just 250 feet away you're allowed to
intimidate at ballot drop boxes in
Arizona as long as you do it from 250
feet away
if you have been following this story as
we have we started to see
armed what do we call them they're armed
so they are gunmen is it a militia I
don't know not really armed people
claiming to be poll Watchers
showing up in and around ballot drop
boxes in Arizona in some cases we have
video of confrontations with people just
dropping off ballots of course
immediately
um the courts were brought into this and
HuffPost and the Associated Press now
report judge orders armed group away
from Arizona ballot drop boxes local and
federal law enforcement have been
alarmed by reports of people some armed
watching 24-hour ballot boxes in two
counties
and a federal judge yesterday ordered
the armed members of this group to stay
at least
250 feet away from the locations
following complaints that people wearing
masks all of a sudden they want to wear
masks and carrying guns were
intimidating voters
wow U.S District Court Judge Michael
Liberty also said members of clean
elections USA its leader and anyone
working with them are barred from
filming or following anyone within 75
feet of a ballot Dropbox or the entrance
of a building that houses one they also
can't speak to or yell at people within
that perimeter unless spoken to First
this is insanity
this is absolute and Total Insanity
armed people monitoring drop boxes it is
a dystopian laughing stock but we kind
of laugh to avoid crying which is really
what we should be doing this is horrible
this is you know I don't want to use
pejorative terms Third World stuff or
whatever this is completely Unbecoming
of the United States and by the way they
can be there they just have to be 250
feet away
it should have happened sooner and it
should be more than 250 feet understand
that 250 feet in many cases means that
they're allowed to be
at the entrance at the sort of driveway
what it was the parking lot I guess what
you would call it at the entrance to the
parking lot to the to the uh locations
of these ballot drop boxes it doesn't
even really change anything often you
have a couple hundred feet particularly
in Arizona where things are so spread
out in many parts of the state so
instead of seeing them right by the
Dropbox itself you see the armed people
as you're driving in to where you would
stop to put your ballots in
uh apparently the intimidation with guns
is okay and it's free speech as long as
you're 250 feet away now there's a real
question here
this has had a chilling effect already
is the court decision too late because
at the end of the day they're simply
being told you've got to be a little
further away and they still might have
had the impact that they want to have
but this should scare all of us and
Arizona is the big state in which we've
learned about this happening for now I
am monitoring for stories of it
happening in other states and if you
come across any please do let me know
but this is you know the the court is
determining whether what is being done
violates the letter of the law
what I am more concerned with is that
all of this and this dates back to six
months before the 2020 election when
they started to hint that if we lose
it's rigged and the mail-in ballots are
fraud and all this different stuff the
the spirit of what it should be to have
an election in the United States of
America has of course been violated by
all of this nonsense going all the way
back let me know what you think find me
on Twitter at dpacman we'll take a very
quick break and be right back before you
go if you enjoyed this video and want to
see more please make sure to subscribe
to my YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also so down below
in the video description